émotion et colère au sein de la police
française après la publication d'un
rapport qui dénonce des comportements et
des pratiques racistes
ce rapport a été établi par deux membres
de la fédération internationale des
droits de l'homme qui se font sur les
contrôles d'identité les gardes à vue en
quête d'ailerons gère et marque ses
listes pendant deux ans il a rencontré
des policiers des avocats des magistrats
et aussi des victimes pour éviter toute
tentative de pression l'auteur du
rapport et étrangers canadien son
jugement sur la police française est
sans appel c'est pouvoir énorme qui leur
sont conférés permet au policier raciste
d'exercer leurs idées elle vit et
d'abuser des pouvoirs qu'ils ont par
exemple qu'elle soit 100 et bien ça peut
être verbalement en humiliant les vins
mais ça peut être aussi physiquement ni
brutalisés
un rapport qui a suscité la colère et
les démentis des syndicats pour qui il
n'y a pas je cite puis de raciste dans
la police que dans le reste de la
société
mais une fois quitté l'uniforme et la
casquette syndicale
ce policier de base a eu le courage de
reconnaître devant nous une part de
vérité au rapport de la fédération des
droits de l'homme
quand le policier mal dans sa peau
effectivement ça va générer en lui des
idées qui sont pas les siens après à la
10e' pas forcément raciste dans le sens
où on contre une race mais raciste il
est aigri de par la société il ne
comprend pas que la société s'intéresse
à d'autres et jamais à lui quand on
parle de racine en alcool immédiatement
le problème du policier dessus en le nom
responsable de tous les faits tous les
maux nation de la société depuis deux
mois daniel kampala a monté avec des
jeunes de montreuil un groupe de
réflexion dialogue difficile
méfiance réciproque le rapport lui
parler de violence de gardes à vue
abusives les noirs les maghrébins
devenant je cite autant de suspects
quand j'entends des copains qui me
disent qu'on ne sont pas arrêtés là
encore abouti
des mots comme sa muse c'est péjoratif
c'est pas ça veut pas dire des gentils
on t'aime bien vous dire toutes les
manifestations là c'est ce que j'ai eu
depuis que je suis en france traitait de
sale a rappelé machin comme ça des
insultes et les manifestations à
sécuriser de la police
la france n'est pas la patrie des droits
de l'homme conclut l'auteur du rapport
et son verdict est sans appel pour vous
la bresse en actions pour un prix resté
dans l'évocation n'y a pas d'alternative
maigre consolation jean claude bernheim
reconnaît que dans son canada natal
comme aux états unis il y a les mêmes
problèmes avec la police